You have looked at these kinds
of demographic trends,
the way our politics has evolved over
the decades in a really in-depth
and detailed way.
And Georgia
is such an interesting example.
I mean, what do you think here?
Help us understand
how much of this is a fundamental shift
or a demographic shift versus
these individual candidates themselves
and of course, the elephant in the room.
Donald Trump.
Yeah, well, look, every election is
there is a intersection of long term
and near term factor.
So all of those figured in.
But to go back to the point
that John Berman finished on.
What we are really seeing
is the impact of the conscious choice
Republicans have made in the Trump
era to reorient
the party toward the cultural preferences
and grievances
of a predominantly white non-urban
non-college, often evangelical electorate,
and the impact that has had on suburban
areas that once reliably voted Republican.
I mean, there were five states, Casey,
as you know, that decided the 2020
election by shifting from Trump in 16
to Biden in 20.
They were Arizona, Georgia,
Michigan, Wisconsin.
Pennsylvania.
With Walker's loss
tonight, Republicans have lost all seven
Republicans in those states
who are nominated for governor or senator
with Trump's
specific endorsement have now lost.
And they've lost in a very consistent way
by having the suburban areas
move sharply against them.
It wasn't just Gwinnett and Cobb.
It was Oakland in Michigan, Delaware
and Montgomery in Pennsylvania,
Maricopa
in Arizona and Dane County in Wisconsin.
So there is a consistent pattern
here of these big populous,
thriving population centers
in the metro areas,
rejecting the Trump era definition
of the party and their increased
strength in the rural areas
not being quite enough to overcome that.
Yeah, no, it's such a good point, Alex.
And I mean, I got to,
as the Republican at the table,
bring you in here because the reality is
the people live in our increasingly inner
cities and suburbs.
And the party is increasingly,
as Ron very clearly laid out.
I'm focusing on a message
that appeals to rural voters,
and there are simply not enough of them
to win no national elections.
And, you know, we're seeing it
in control of the Senate.
There's obviously very narrow control
of the House on the Republican side,
almost not enough that I'm not even sure
exactly what we can take away
from the way the House switch this year.
But I mean, how do
and how can Republicans win back
these voters that they need to win
if they want the White House back?
Well, they can start with nominating
quality candidates.
Candidate quality was a big factor
in a lot of these races
that Ron mentioned, that we lost people
that were flawed candidates
that were backed by Trump
election deniers,
we're okay with the January 6th
insurrection at the Capitol
that did not sit well with voters.
So getting quality candidates
that focus on issues that are important
to voters is really important.
And this, I think, will go a long way
to what I'm going to say next.
Ronna McDaniel, the
chairwoman
of the Republican National Committee,
she was put in that position in 2017.
She has been in that position.
We have Republicans
have not won across the board in any races
since she has been in office.
I think change starts at the top
in order for Republicans
to do well moving forward.
Change needs to begin at the top
and therefore
someone like her
in a position of the head of the RNC
get candidates in the primary process
that can win in the general election.
This is not about winning
primaries. It's about winning the general.
I take your point.
But at the end of the day and Paul Begala,
I'm interested in your take on this.
At the end of the day,
a big part of this is that the best people
in the Republican Party haven't wanted
to put themselves in positions to run
for these offices, to run for Senate.
I mean, we had.
You mean Chris Sununu in New Hampshire.
There are
there were others kind of across the map
that Mitch McConnell really wanted to run
and who didn't run because nobody wanted
anything to do with Trump.
I mean, how do they solve that problem?
We're not talking
about the Maryland Senate race
because the incumbent won in a landslide,
the Democrat, because Larry Hogan,
the incredibly popular Republican governor
of one of the most Democratic states
didn't want anything to do.
Of course,
the politics in the time of Trump
in the U.S.,
I mean, he's going to run for president.
But what? And we we wish him well.
But I think the problem
is not even just geographic.
Right.
They do have a problem in the cities
and in the suburbs.
But it's it's what they say,
you know, right after the Civil War.
Henry Adams, a historian and writer
and diplomat, he described
American politics in his day
as the systematic organization of hatreds.
That's Donald Trump's politics.
If he were going to rural America and say,
I'm going to help save rural hospitals,
you know,
one third of all the rural hospitals
in America are under risk of closing.
That's a crisis.
There's a crisis on the farm.
God knows there's an opioid crisis
in every part of America,
but it's hitting rural America.
If he were going to them with ideas
and solutions for their very real
problems, there'd be one thing.
Instead, he's going with grievance.
Look at Mr.
Walker running ads attacking trans kids,
of which I think in high school athletics
in Georgia, there are two and we know
that trans kids have spectacularly higher
suicide ideations and self-harm.
And that's just it has failed politically.
But I also think morally it's wrong.
It's better to come to voters
with something
you'll do for them than just
I hate to say, people you hate.